clearly communicate your successes this
of course starts with first you're
having a clear understanding what your
successes are but then second also
communicating them and this might be in
your weekly one-on-ones you're having
with your direct supervisor to make sure
that you are also going over the topics
you completed last week what the result
was what the impact was another
technique very commonly applied in
Consulting and I'd say very helpful for
other roles as well our end of week
emails so we'll be very common for
project leads sometimes even senior
Associates to write a summary of the
week at the end of the week highlighting
first the highlights second the low
lights and third what are the next steps
right that you are facing in the next
week